comme ce collectif d'artistes depuis un
peu plus d'un an 250 martiniquais ont
fait cette démarche spontanée faire
analyser loto de chlordécone dans leur
sang pour les biologistes le nombre est
déjà significative pour dégager une
tendance
un quart des personnes testées sont
positives à des degrés divers
pourtant ce sont des individus
conscients de la contamination est
attentif à leur nutrition
les taux seront donc plus élevée dans la
population générale 25% c'est déjà
beaucoup
et d'autant plus qu' il n'ya pas
seulement que le chlordécone il y aussi
les autres pesticides à ce n'est pas
tout en effet les biologistes
recherchent et trouvent une trentaine
d'organes ou chlorés différent des
organochlorés qu'on a utilisé par le
passé comme le ddt ou le lindane que
l'on retrouve d'ailleurs sur les
résultats des patients qu'ils sont des
perturbateurs endocriniens et auront une
incidence à doses très très infime sur
l'organisme
ça peut être des perturbations
endocriniennes certains cancers comme ce
cancer de la prostate
ban il y a défini le ddt est donc très
rémanents dans les sols comme dans notre
organisme
j'ai déjà eu mon fils cadet qui a qui a
été contaminé par des poupées des
pesticides il avait que 15 ans nous
habitions parlons d'une maladresse et
les appels des dépannages aérien et donc
il était hospitalisé à cause de ça il a
eu les branches dilatés et les médecins
nous ont dit que c'était lié aux
pesticides et voilà le chlordécone lui
fini par s'éliminer de l'organisme après
quelques mois d'alimentation saine
en espérant que la santé n'est pas déjà
impactés
ce sera une inquiétude pour vous lorsque
vous allez lire le résultat ses analyses
mais j'ai peur monsieur j'ai vraiment
pas confiné à risoul un peu loose ulta
c'est pas de 12 ans après monsieur je
peux passer pour moi c'est pas pour mon
pays
alors pour les volontaires aujourd'hui
il faut multiplier ses analyses et
révélé les chiffres et je pense qu'avec
des chiffres
les gens pourront réaliser beaucoup
mieux l'impact que cela peut avoir sur
notre vie et que se dire que c'est un
uniquement quelque chose qu'ils
entendent le quéré a étrillé réel les
analyses envoyer l'image sont rendus
sous trois semaines non remboursés par
la sécurité sociale leur tarif initial
de 140 euro a baissé à 68 euros grâce à
certains accords le résultat ne
répondent pas à toutes nos
interrogations
c'est pourquoi elle demeure un geste
militant